good evening breaking news tonight
stimulus is on the way
congress passing the 900 billion cobit
rescue package tonight
all it needs now is the president's
signature so
what does this plan do well in part it
provides a six hundred dollar
one-time check for people making under
seventy five thousand dollars a year
with varying amounts going out to those
making up to ninety nine thousand
it does extend pua benefits and it
extends the ppp loan program for small
businesses
but we know your question is when will
you see that money
experts say could take up to two weeks
for the treasury to get cash into your
bank account
and hear cbs reporter skyler henry with
more
congress has passed the 900 billion
dollar covid relief package as part of a
larger bill to fund the federal
government through september 2021
the american people have waited long
enough
under the legislation 600 dollar
stimulus checks will be sent to people
who make less than seventy five
thousand dollars a year they will also
get six hundred dollars for each of
their dependents
it also includes three hundred dollars a
week in federal unemployment benefits
for the next ten weeks
we've come together we've done something
important and i think we've set the
stage for perhaps something later
in the next congress treasury secretary
steven mnuchin says the checks could
start going out next week
this is as close to a christmas miracle
as you can find
in a polarized washington the white
house says the president looks forward
to signing the bill
in a statement president-elect joe biden
praised the agreement but
also added more will still need to be
done on monday mr biden received the
coronavirus vaccine at a hospital near
his home in delaware
the shot was administered on camera i'm
doing this to demonstrate
that people should be prepared when it's
available to take the vaccine there's
nothing to worry about
the president-elect said the trump
administration deserves some credit for
operation war of speed
the federal effort to develop
coronavirus vaccines biden also urged
everyone to continue to wear masks and
practice social distancing when around
other people
skylar nrap cbs news capitol hill
so now the relief package also includes
several directives that have to do with
nevada
including a no funding for nuclear waste
disposal at yucca mountain